flying a fighter a lot of people are
like you're just in the seat how
difficult could it be but we are pulling
upwards of nine G's nine times the force
of gravity so right now I'm at 1G I
weigh about 200 pounds 230 with my gear
on at 9 G's that's over 2 000 pounds of
force just crushing you into your seat
and you know as you saw Tito Ortiz one
of the most fit people on the planet
ninth person ever to be inducted into
the UFC Hall of Fame he wanted to come
out and see what fighter pilot training
was like so we put him into the nastar
centrifuge nine G's nine times the force
of gravity he ended up G locking so
that's a g-induced loss of consciousness
with the forces that were pulling it's
vertical so it's pulling the blood out
of your brain and putting it into your
extremities and it's doing it with
enough force that it can rupture your
blood vessels so after a flight it'll
look like I have chickenpox on my arms
and my legs and that's from that
pressure of the blood eruptions as blood
vessels but the real threat is passing
out if you lose enough blood you'll pass
out